wir haben tatsächlich zwölf
crew-mitglieder wo wir positive
testergebnis übermittelt bekommen haben
und noch ein schritt zurück das haben
sie gerade gesehen wir fahren aktuell
mit drei schiffen und einem sehr
strengen hygiene und gesundheitskonzept
und bisher hatten wir auch keine
vorfälle nur zufriedene gäste und ein
teil dieses konzept ist dass wir gäste
und besatzung vorab testen bevor sie an
bord gehen das heißt es kommen nur
negativ getesteten menschen an bord und
bei der crew gehen wir noch einen
schritt weiter und testen routinemäßig
und bei diesen routinetests haben wir
zwölf testergebnis übermittelt bekommen
von griechischen labors und dem gehen
wir natürlich nachgegangen ist es so
dass wir an bord im hospital das wurde
auch gerade gezeigt haben wir ein
kleines mini testgerät ein labor und das
haben wir jetzt aktiviert das heißt alle
zwölf besatzungsmitglieder wurden den
tag über getestet wir haben auch schon
test testergebnisse zurückgekommen und
zwar von diesen zwölf sind sechs
testergebnisse der zweiten tests sind
negativ ja und die weiteren
testergebnisse die erwarten wir im laufe
des des tages sie liegen spätestens
morgen vor und es gibt ganz strenge
prozesse wie wir mit solchen
verdachtsfällen umgehen
und zwar werden die besatzungsmitglieder
umgehend isoliert auf sogenannten
quarantäne kabinen und dort bleibt sie
auch bis wir dann tatsächlich wissen ob
sie sich infiziert haben oder nicht und
all diese besatzungsmitgliedern geht es
hervorragend überhaupt keine symptome
und wir gehen jetzt in diesen positiven
testergebnissen nach ob das denn
tatsächlich so haltbar ist oder nicht
und wie sieht es aus mit der kreuzfahrt
im allgemeinen wird jetzt irgendwie die
zur geändert sind die pläne jetzt anders
wie läuft das jetzt ab ja es ist
tatsächlich so dass wir entsprechend
unserer fahrplan planung morgen in
piräus anlegen das war auch genauso gut
genauso geplant bei den gästen
entschuldigung und wie es dann weiter
geht das wenn wir gemeinsam mit den
griechischen gehören besprechen und
natürlich auch sein denn wenn sich da
aber wir müssen einfach schauen wie die
weiteren testergebnisse sich sich
entwickeln wie gesagt morgen morgen
wissen wir da mehr aber es besteht
keinerlei sorge für besatzung und gäste
so viel steht schon mal fest
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren